un atelier en pleine ébullition pour les
étudiants c'est le rêve nouveau départ
s'approprier enfin un métier autrement
inaccessibles alors qu'on a eu on a déjà
notre famille on a les mains vides sauf
que on peut pas se permettre de tout
abandonner son os pour retourner à
l'école
même si ça serait la chose à faire ces
hommes et ces femmes sont payées pour
apprendre 20 $ de l'heure pendant 17
semaines
est ce que tu pourrais me dire quel
candidat novès voilà où on est rendu
blais industrie l'entreprise à des
chantiers miniers partout dans le monde
mais ici en abitibi difficile de
répondre à la demande
parfois il ya des clients qui seraient
prêt à m'en prendre exemple une équipe
de 50 et nous on est seulement mesure de
lui en fournir une vingtaine d fois
carrément ont dit non on peut pas
soumissionner sur ce contrôle
faute de main d'oeuvre qualifiée où que
vous alliez peu importe l'industrie le
signal est le même
le message est le même
l'abitibi-témiscamingue est en pénurie
de main d'oeuvre
même le mcdonald's à val d'or n'est
ouvert qu'à temps partiel
[Musique]
les écoles de formation professionnelle
manque par maman d'élève
le taux de placement est à 100% et aucun
problème pour pour l'emploi c'est le on
a de la difficulté à recruter des
étudiants partout au québec le
vieillissement de la population au fait
mal les départs à la retraite s'accélère
la relève manque à l'appel
ajouter le boom minier et le manque à
gagner en abitibi témiscamingue et
criant partout
les minières embauche développent de
nouveaux projets et finissent par privé
cette entreprise de leur main d'oeuvre
ce soir abrite toute la semaine qui va
c'est inhabituel d habitude ça déborde
pas des carreaux comme ceux de quoi
donner des sueurs froides à éric beaupré
des fois le sait beaucoup de nuls
blanche techno sommes produire et par
des pompes submersibles ou les mines
départ à la retraite en premier débouché
l'entreprise ne fournit plus c'est
devenu critique pour nos opérations donc
toute l'économie voit bien et nous
autres bains
vous l'avez vu ça rentre ça rende sa
rente et en os de l'est on les respecte
moins cons et qu'on était capable
technoserve a donc pris les grands
moyens a fait le pari de recruter des
travailleurs
aux philippines six hommes hautement
qualifiés attendu avec impatience
on n'a pas le choix madame parce qu on
sera plus capable de livrer donc c'est
notre survie notre futur qui en dépend
il n'est pas le seul
les garages et concessionnaires de rouyn
noranda sont aux prises avec le même
problème
une soixantaine de mécaniciens et
machinistes philippins sont attendues à
moins au cours des prochains mois
solution radicale
un problème qui semble insurmontable
autrement technos homme qui recrutent
aux philippines le problème est tel que
les élus de la région se sont regroupés
pour tenter de trouver les solutions
selon la mairesse de rouyn noranda
l'immigration doit faire partie de la
solution
dans les années 30 dans les débuts
l'exploration minière
c'était la région qui est qui avait le
plus d'immigrants un tiers de la
population était composée des migrants
fois que les gens viennent chez nous ils
veulent y rester alors nous ne trop ce
sera d amener chine d'ici à ce qu'une
stratégie globale soit articulé chacun
assume le risque est investi de grosses
sommes enfin une semaine à peu près de 7
à la maison construire ma serrure pour
blaye industrie ces quelques 15 mille
dollars par étudiant non l'espoir que
ceux-ci demeurons fidèles à l'entreprise
je crois qu'à long terme de pouvoir les
former et vraiment qu'ils puissent
adhérer à nos valeurs c'est ça qu'on
veut
notre souhait ce qu'ils puissent rester
le plus longtemps chez nous mêmes
risques financiers pour technophobes
éric beaupré espère surtout trouver une
façon d'intégrer ses fils y perd son
équipe tissée serrée sa communauté
toutes les entreprises est que l'on a
avec lesquels on ne parlait en beauce en
estrie qui ont des philippines zone du
sadisme
usine à 13h éric beaupré n'attend pas de
voir les résultats déjà il s'apprête à
les recruter des travailleurs
au mexique on sait que l'immigration ce
pas toujours populaires au québec ce
dossier chaud mais on peut pas attendre
la politique loin des grands centres les
entreprises d'abitibi témiscamingue se
sentent bien seuls par moments avec deux
projets miniers majeurs à l'horizon
plusieurs craignent aussi que le
problème n'ira qu'en sa table